oh thank an exclusive that's right fat
975 blazing today's hottest music
bootleg caps am I am saying care you
live in studio man 50 cent ladies and
gentlemen yeah man 50 welcome back to
the city I notice kind of something like
a second home to you man yeah I've been
out a little bit cuz i come back and
forth to hang with florida and you know
why he's during the camp you know I came
out to support indeed you know so they
should be really looking forward to
tomorrow night because are you bringing
flight out tomorrow put on a great show
something like that you know yeah yeah
I'm like that alright that's what's up
cuz I remember the last the last fight
he was right in the ring without
everything went down yeah yeah the punch
everybody was talking about like you
know what's really interesting is is
people don't really identify with how
long we've been friends ok let me Floyd
been fired by almost 11 years now ok so
like he uh to be honest it just really
see they see us around each other hmm
because this cycle has been longer than
any other album cycle opening right I've
had time free time I've been able to
come out and hang out yeah definitely
man shout out to fifties in studio right
now man so I saw you you did tweet a
release date for a possible new album
july second yeah yeah is that sticking
yeah I feel good about my pride my
project is it's pretty much done but I'm
not done writing ok I've done before 10
joints for this gangsta grillz yeah the
gangsta grillz manda the riot joint that
that's everyone's talking about 10
Chinese joint I just work cuz I just
dropped that like what was it yesterday
it was yesterday yeah so that's all over
the place and then um before that was
the aisle Qaeda bomb you must know I'm
with me snoopin Paris that's your uh
your female MC a okay precious Paris it
you know it's interesting cuz a long
time ago like when I first fell in love
with hip-hop the females that were
involved the my period where things were
like really interesting to me was like
they were from Brooklyn it was you know
cam man foxy from Brooklyn yeah now I
was just starting to feel like they can
read beef
Queens for AJ's shout out to Nicki yes I
could be Nikki in Paris to be out there
in a second um I wanted to ask you man
um as far as hip-hop is concerned like
like I was telling you we would have a
good conversation off the air man like
you you drop in get rich or die trying'
kind of like it was it was like the if
we were saying our fair i told you that
someone asked me what's the album to
kind of define your like high school
years i get to me it's your album you
know I mean though it's really
interesting is music is important in
that way because it marks time it marks
time and it's funny because I can
remember going and copping the double XL
magazine would you amon and Dre on it
yeah and it had that special had an
extra DVD in it yeah it was yeah I
remember that too we shot that actually
we shot the photograph for that at the
in the club video shoot that's crazy man
it's just it's just it doesn't seem like
it was that long ago you know what I'm
saying but it was like what ten years
ago yeah almost ya know this is old
school at known it's time for something
new indeed my brother indeed a so the
new album july second can you too can
you reveal the title yet now i haven't
revealed the title I'm still you know
conceptually I don't even know what I'm
writing talk hunt with the title at
actual album and I did that and I've
made changes based on what I'm actually
tiling and now but I'm not going to just
what direction on what direction
musically are you taking it back to to
uh so you know what Richard I lack
trying days or when people see when you
say take it back mention i live in any
room for growth alright well yeah I mean
I suarez day back the content 10 years
ago right and I like for me I think it
has that energy that they were attracted
to on give it to document on it yes all
the way across the board is there I just
think um the way I articulated things on
this actual project my choices on it or
are better okay I think I'm better I can
I'm everybody grows get it out you know
I'm saying like thinking it out a little
more so they'll get a chance to see
where I'm at play away man can't wait oh
yeah I may even wait the gangsta grillz
reflect some of it you know I'm just
going to keep going I'm starting over so
you know some artists
it get places they become complacent
because they've had some success and a
lot of leeway even prepared for this
actual fight you know you go back and
you treat each opponent like they're the
best fighter in the world and you got to
face them not just someone that you
think is a pushover and coming in i
watch Floyd do that so I'm excited about
the actual fight and and on the joints
we're gonna party we're gonna party at
the party get off the palms rain right
yeah yeah be on the night after that's
what it is so 50 um I gotta ask you man
you are coming up as a New York MC of
course um today mca from bc boys passed
away yeah yeah um what I mean did you
ever have any experiences with him I
mean that that's one of the most
influential groups after that I've had
an opportunity to open for them for run
DMC okay who was actually on the same
bill with what of the Beastie Boys vc
boys at the time and guys chance to
watch both for their shows afterwards
you know how crazy it is the first song
that I ever had on vinyl is called a
glow okay so you look on youtube you
just hear this is the glow glow of a dog
a glow of love member that Luther
Vandross yeah yeah yeah we took the loop
and I back to that and I went on and I I
performed that before run dnj started
their set okay and I it was a really
good experience for me I saw so out in
front of them that was the very first
time i was on a stage perform an
original in demon um i also wanted to
bring up something that always kind of
feel like happens to a lot of the bigger
artists like I kind of felt its kind of
happened to Drake lately at to me it
kind of happened to you where you came
out and everybody was loving them from
50 and then as soon as you kind of hit a
certain level of success it seems like a
lot of your fans started doing the whole
you know they kind of disassociated
themselves from look from you I feel
like that's kind of happening think that
comes from the actual artist community
you think so I think they feel like if
you don't move I can't be next if you
stay right in a slot to train with your
the number one guy right there
that um they need you to move and they
help influence each other until they go
no it's not what it used to be you know
don't feel the same right whatever it is
but it's the cycle of success you know
if you're lucky enough to have success
you'll work your way through that period
anyone's career as long enough as peaks
and valleys in it and d man indeed with
the new album um what what do you need
this album to do to consider it a
success in your eyes just good a great
response from the general public because
I can't gauge it on numbers I had the
largest debuting hip hop out a cell 13
million record can yet and especially
the time climbing today it's not really
it's almost impossible and then I mean
the second album did 10 million so like
what do you you can't gauge it on actual
sales for me personally it would have to
be on how the people receive it how
passionate people receive it and again
the way you look at your high school
experience yup say this is my freshman
high school experience that's it I it
needs to be that for something new for
some new kids right indie man indeed am
as far as like the music climate right
now like a so many new MCS coming out
it's so much music to consume that's out
there do the internet and stuff how I
mean do you enjoy the way it is now or
do you kind of miss when you really had
to put in work I miss when you had to
have what you're actually writing about
right like your experience right right
right now you don't have to cuz now it's
like almost like a hipster vibe or it's
very it's very it's very it's very
different say something if it sounds
cool okay good you got it it almost
seems like no you don't have to come
from anything like that within your
lifestyle background or experience like
if for me if I don't use something for
my life this relevant is real then I
can't even figure out why i want to
write the song like I lose indeed um
when you came out it was kind of like it
was like a breath of fresh air there
wasn't really any really aggressive
music coming like that was really um
representing hip hop on a mainstream
field right you know so when you dropped
that was kind of like kind of like when
dmx drop previously was DMX was the
the wave that came before for you and
then 50 do you feel like there's anybody
who's coming I feel like right now like
you were just saying musics kind of like
on the hips I feel like someone needs to
come through with some of that that
Gangstar ish like yeah but that doesn't
mean I think that's really effective you
know if you don't actually have that and
yet background right so like if you're
not from that then and you you see
anybody who might kinda I mean I think a
lot of people might say I know you don't
mess with Ross but meek millz kind of
kind of that like me you like my um I
watched him boys from the beginning when
he had braids on his head before he
actually went to he was locked up a lil
while right now i'm saying so on him
cheek raw um bunch of the philly mike
knox Phillies village only got a lot of
rappers out there a real writers again
i'm saying and then there's a lot of
Joey jihad mmm you know I mean um
there's so many of them like like it was
a whole coke I mean vodka right you know
it's a lot of them so I used to sit and
watch like watch the clip some stuff
like that so when he got his break he'll
tell you if the icing that I was
actually gonna sign oh okay that's
what's up man um but the whole Rick Ross
situation I mean it kind of seems like
Ross is kind of um you know that dude
right now in the hip-hop game you guys
went through your spat you know what you
get when a person works is just couldn't
you just offer consistency consistency
is key to all success and while I was
building business in other areas like I
show you like you got headphones you got
the vitaminwater you know I get what I
come from every time i get the same
light as a I just I was just like when I
decide to make the gangsta grillz an
issue you hear materially people get
excited about yep but I walk like that
we don't call the money team ain't got
no money hold up this do 50 disorder he
just pulled out that's four hundred
thousand four hundred grand right now on
the table all right a man 50 you gotta
let me take a twitpic with that what we
do my goodness next other guys to do it
when they come with a little bitter
hahaha they gotta have it